I think Dusty settles within a month. I think without the YouTube
income coming in to continue this case and and without the the
motion to terminate, right, or to to dismiss, I think he settles
>> I don't get a
poor and homeless. >> What are they saying for you to >> then?
And that's pretty obvious that there's no 14th month. He's with
a minor here. He is with a minor here. Factually, yes, factually
correct. These are sex. This is him with a minor. Yep. >> What
I'm not sure happened and maybe I'm just missing something. So,
I'm I think I should I'm not understanding cuz what I think happened
can't really be this stupid. Okay. >> Because I I just
think you can't afford to keep paying. You can't afford for this
to go to court, right? No matter what you lose.
But today, okay, September 19th, there's a motion to submit audio
exhibit conventionally in connection with motion to dismiss.
So, some something about an audio thing. And then um
there's like a big motion to dismiss over lack of jurisdiction
and then there's a declaration for Destiny, declaration for Bretler.
They're basically going to try to disprove the Abby logs and
then say that they don't have jurisdiction. Now I think the problem
is I don't know if this works. Look at Breler spamming exhibits
in such an unhinged manner. Dude, this is expensive. This is
like double expensive. Okay, this is like double expensive when
you think about it. He's got to pay Andy B and he's not getting
that YouTube income anymore. This is rough. Okay, this is rough.
This is a tough situation to be in. Okay, let me let me look
at the main document. Main document we got. What do we How should
we read this? Cuz I know this is going to reference some of the
exhibits. So, I don't know if we should just wait and do the
exhibits in order as they get referenced or if we should start
with like the exhibits first. I know some people started with
the exhibits first. I'm guessing the overall arc of the argument
is going to be here's our argument for why the Abby stuff is
not admissible, not true, not real. And then from there, we're
going to say, "Hey,
because that stuff's not real. You have no subject matter jurisdiction."
Now, I think with the Abby stuff, he's going to say, "Here's
these logs that I have um that prove I didn't do it, but it's
like those are editable logs you have." I don't know. I don't
know how that argument is going to go. They say, "Read the main
dock." Okay, I'm guessing. Okay, I'm going to make some predictions.
Okay, one one quick prediction. All right, I
think that if this were to fail, Destiny will settle. I think
Destiny settles within a month. I think without the YouTube income
coming in to continue this case and and without the the motion
to terminate, right, or to to dismiss, I think he settles immediately
because I I just think you can't afford to keep paying. you can't
afford for this to go to court, right? No matter what, you lose.
I think he pays to settle and I think it's like, o, I think it's
going to be painful, too. Guess he's too hard-headed. I don't
know, man. >> I think when you got like when you've got
like 500 grand coming in a month or some, it's easy to make decisions
like it's easy to stand on business for >> Uh, venomous
villain with the five gifted. Let's go. Thank you very much,
venomous villain. It's easy to stand on business when you got
a lot of money coming in. Okay. It's a lot harder to stand on
business if you don't have that money coming in. It's a lot more
difficult. Okay.
Trump's going to debank him at this point. I don't know about
that. We'll see. We'll see. Let's start reading this and then
we'll we'll see what we need as we go along. Okay. Let's check
it out. Introduction.
As as Steven Benell, previously known as Destiny, has consistently
maintained from the outset of the case, the court lacks subject
matter jurisdiction over this dispute. Plaintiff's amended complaint
does nothing to cure that fatal defect. For that reason, in the
court's September 2nd, 2025 order granting plaintiff's motion
for leave to file an amended complaint ECF,
what is it? ECF number 119, Magistrate Judge Torres invited Banell
to file the instant motion to dismiss pursuant to rule 12b1 of
the federal rules of civil procedure. Count one of the amended
complaint for Banell's alleged violation of 15 USC 68 section
6851. Cardi
civil
oh what is it? Civil something for distribution of intimate images
for civil action regarding in distribution of intimate images.
Cardi yes nailed it. Nailed it from memory. Provides the sole
basis for the federal question jurisdiction. Yet count one fails
as a matter of law. Evidence inconsistent with the allegations
in the amended complaint conclusively establishes that Benell
transmitted the video depicting plaintiff on just one. No, it
doesn't. What? Evidence inconsistent with the al Oh, sorry. Sorry.
Evidence inconsistent with the allegations in the amended complaint.
So, he's going to say, "I can prove that this didn't happen."
Which is factually incorrect, right? Like, they won't be able
to prove this. This will be a matter for court to decide. Like,
this will not be something that the judges have the expertise
to decide. So, I'm already going to declare that I don't I don't
think this stands on super strong grounds. Right?
So, they're going to say, "Well, this evidence," but then people
are going to say, "Well, wait, but could this have happened any
other way? Is there another source for this evidence?" Right?
If if for some reason they let's say Discovery had gone through
and they had the Discord logs from back then. Let's say the Discord
logs from back then were saved and like a third party retrieved
from Discord set of logs say okay he didn't transmit it then
maybe they have an argument. But if it's just his if it's just
his logs I don't know if he could make that argument necessarily.
I don't know if a court could decide that. I think they have
to put that in front of a jury or something with experts. And
Abby has to show up to be a witness for what? I I don't know
if I've seen anything that orders her to show up. She has to
show up to court itself for it to count as evidence, right? For
them to use this as evidence, she has to be willing to testify
on it. But that won't that doesn't necessarily have to happen
before anything. She's not been subpoenaed to testify before
the court yet, as far as I know. Anyway, I I don't think that's
even true. Junarch, I don't think that's true yet. Uh, but we'll
we'll watch. We'll we'll check it out here. We'll uh Where are
we at here? Evidence inconsistent with the allegations in amended
complaint conclusively establishes that Benell transmitted the
video depicting plaintiff on just one occasion to an individual
who used the screen name Rose in April 2022. That sole transmission
of the video preceded preceded the effective date of the Cardi
statute by nearly 6 months because the statute is not retroactive.
The court lacks subject matter jurisdiction over plaintiff's
federal claim and should declined to exercise supplemental jurisdiction
over plaintiff's pendant state law claims conceding that Benel's
sole transmission of the video to Rose could not serve as the
basis for subject matter
plaintiff amended her complaint on uh no she did not she literally
did not concede this or sorry I guess this was conceded but this
is not the only piece of evidence they have or not the only piece
of evidence they claim right conceding that panel's sole transmission
of the video to Rose could not serve as the basis for subject
matter jurisdiction. Plaintiff amended her complaint on September
5th, 2025 ECF number 120 to add an allegation that Benel transmitted
the video to an individual who used the screen name ABMC and
sometime after March 2023. Plaintiff's new allegation pertaining
to an alleged transmission to ABMC is not consistent with the
evidence. In fact, the evidence demonstrates just the opposite.
I.e. Benell did not transmit the video to ABMC at any time. Plaintiff's
new allegation concerning ABMC relies exclusively on a declaration
and exhibit purportedly from ABMC CCF number 86 that plaintiff
filed with the court on the day before June 3rd 2025 evidentiary
hearing on the plaintiff's motion for a preliminary injunction
a month after that motion was fully brief uh briefed. Plaintiff
conceded or contends that the ABMC declaration establishes that
Benell transmitted the video to ABMC in 2023 but her declaration
does no such thing. Plaintiff who's okay I mean it's the testimony.
It's the testimony. That's it. They're okay. But they they said
without conceding and I thought the judge accepted that language
without conceding that the uh amended complaint was deficient.
So they can say that, but I thought it was already accepted that
it was without admitting that the original complaint was deficient,
right? Because they still say the timeline is is inconsistent.
So they'd have to disprove the timeline discrepancies as well
here, which I think they do. I think Destiny provides his logs
from his side if I remember correctly. It's a reason Abby wouldn't
show up to court. Not that I know of.
continue. Uh, plaintiff contends that ABMC declaration establishes
the Vanel transmitted the video to ABMC in 2023, but her declaration
does no such thing. Plaintiff, whose attorney also represents
ABMC, could have submitted proof from ABMC of any such transmission
from Banell. Yet, she has not done so, and for good reason. As
explained below, the evidence demonstrates that the transmission
never occurred. Okay. Plaintiff has been on notice of Banell's
jurisdictional challenge since he filed his answer in affirmative
defenses on March 14th, 2025, ECF number 17. Banell repeated
the challenge in his April 20 25th, 2025 opposition to plaintiff's
motion for preliminary injunction ECF number 42. For more than
6 months, plaintiff has had the opportunity to demonstrate through
admissible evidence that Benell actually transmitted the video
to ABMC or to anyone else after the effective date of the Cardi
statute. She has failed to do so yet makes allegations in her
amended complaint that are wholly inconsistent with the evidence
in the record. Indeed, plaintiff failed to produce her star witness
ABMC to testify at the June 3rd, 2025 evidentiary hearing, depriving
Banell of the opportunity to her and test the contentions in
her declaration.
Well, hold on. Banell was aware of her. Banell was asking questions
about her before this. He could have easily subpoenaed this person.
Isn't that the judge's contention? Why didn't you actually subpoena
this person? You have the ability to do so. I thought the judge
said that. Maybe I'm crazy. Worse, for more than four months,
ABMC has dodged and evaded service of a valid subpoena. According
to ABMC's plaintiff, uh, ABMC plaintiff's council, who is also
her attorney, advised her to continue to evade service just to
submit evidence anyway.
And just to submit evidence anyway, according to ABMC, plaintiff's
council, who is also her attorney, advised her to continue to
evade service and just to submit evidence anyway. Oh, so apparently
Abby said this somewhere. I guess we'll see. Plaintiff has not
and cannot submit any evidence to establish that Benell transmitted
the video after the effective date of the statute. In fact, today
plaintiff has submitted has submitted no evidence apart from
ABMC's unsworn statement.
Wait, it's a statement under penalty of perjury. It's the same
thing. It's literally a statement under penalty of perjury. That's
the same thing as a sworn statement. Huh?
So, unsworth statement to demonstrate that Banell transmitted
the video to ABMC ever. But now on the other hand, Destiny's
been saying this, but there's ne there's never been um any proof
of this, right? From what I've seen, there's been no proof of
this in any case. Destiny said this, but this has never been
established as far as I know. Not from anything I've seen, but
I also haven't watched anything Aby's been doing. I know she's
been in Discords and talking on streams and stuff, so it's possible
she said something. I have no idea. Oh, the judge did say that
about Rose. That's true. Yeah, it wasn't about Abby, but I think
the judge did say something like there was just no reason for
Abby to have been there, right? Destiny statements are also unsworn,
by the way. Yeah, but they're they're statements under penalty
of perjury. They're statements you make because you're not going
to swear in a Bible, right? Like I thought they were statements
under penalty of perjury. There are literally penalties to lying
in these statements and you are agreeing to basically testify
if called upon. I thought that was the I thought we looked that
up a long time ago. Like the unsworn thing is meant to seem make
it seem like when when he does this when when Andrew Britler
says unsworn statement. It's meant to undermine the statement,
but I don't think it does that for the judge. I think this is
for PR, right? This is so somebody can go on stream and read
this and go, "Oh, she's not even swearing. It's true." But it's
like if you looked up any of the stuff, you just know that this
is like it's still something under penalty of perjury. Like if
you lie here, you would be in big trouble
or you face penalties at least.
Um, in fact, to date, plaintiffs submitted no evidence apart
from ABMC's unsworn statement to demonstrate that Banell transmitted
the video to ABMC ever. Banell, on the other hand, has conclusively
established that no such transmission occurred. The court should
dismiss plaintiff's amended complaint accordingly. So, they're
saying that with one of the admissions today or submissions,
one of the exhibits, they'll show conclusively that he didn't.
I don't understand how that would be possible just from his logs
alone.
Um, he could literally just delete the file, right? He like that's
he could just delete the message. It was like an HTML page. Now
that would be brazen obviously,
but I don't know how you could conclusively establish this. Um
factual and procedural background. On April 3rd, 2025, plaintiff
filed a motion for a temporary restraining order and preliminary
injunction against Bell. On April 25th, 2025, Banell filed his
opposition to plaintiff's motion ECF42.
Uh among other arguments, Benell opposed plaintiff's motion on
the grounds that the court lacks lacks subject matter jurisdiction
over the this action because plaintiff failed to adequately allege
that Banell transmitted the video after. So this is the same
declar the same thing they've said each time. Uh he sent it to
to Rose way before the date, 6 months before the date on April
29th, 2025. Council for Bennell received a letter for plaintiff's
attorney Carlos A. Garcia Perez indicating that he and his law
firm represented ABMC specifically pertaining to Steven K. Benell
II Breler declaration here just 3 days later on May 2nd 2025
plaintiff filed her reply brief in support of her motion for
preliminary injunction a day after the her reply papers were
due on May 3rd 2025
plaintiff filed a declaration purportedly from ABMC along with
exhibits these exhibits
um on May 14th 2025 by the way they they said repeatedly they
don't care about this right that it's like a day late and it
sucks but it's like not not egregious or something uh on May
14th, 2025, council for Bunnell emailed plaintiff's council to
inquire whether they would agree to accept service of a subpoena
on behalf of their client ABMC. Breler declaration paragraph
five and exhibit C. Having received no response from plaintiff's
council on May 16th, 2025, Banell's attorneys provided them with
notice of issuance of a subpoena and a copy of the subpoena Banell
issued to ABMC on May 15th, 2025.
Um, previously referenced exhibit C, paragraph 6, and exhibit
D. Thereafter, Benell Banell's council arranged for a process
server to serve the subpoena personally on ABMC at any of her
publicly available addresses. Uh, same declarations, paragraph
7. Despite multiple attempts to serve ABMC with the subpoena,
Banell was unable to serve her.
On June 2nd, 2025, plaintiff blatantly filed her motion to file
redacted evidence in support of the declaration of ABMC ECF number
86. Plaintiffs sought to submit new purported evidence to bolster
the ABMC declaration, namely a November 3rd, 2023 text message
that Abby supposedly sent to an unknown person stating, "I have
videos of him these people like Lauo. He just sent me another
one. Haven't opened it." ECF 861.
Plaintiff contends that this text message directly corroborates
the testimony of ABMC in her declaration ECF 86 at 2. On June
3rd, 2025, the court held a hearing on plaintiff's motion for
preliminary injunction ECF number 87.
See here, why are they just blogging the ongoings of the court?
Um, I don't know. I guess they probably don't know and they probably
wouldn't want the judges to have to go read everything and maintain
like a perfect memory. They probably do tell the the whole story
that they need as if this document was the only thing you were
reading, right? So, they don't want you to have to go back and
remember everything. They're going to say, "Here's like all the
stuff you need." On June 3rd, 2025, the court held a hearing
on plaintiff's motion for preliminary injunction.
Despite the count that council for plaintiff also represents
ABMC
and despite that plaintiff relies on ABMC's critical testimony
to establish subject matter jurisdiction, plaintiff failed to
produce ABMC to testify at the hearing.
So, I would just like to go back right now and let me just go
see where the judge actually talks about this, right? Cuz I think
I think this is referenced in what is this? The response response
in opposition to motion swore a motion unopposed motion. Where's
the judge's like actual order here? Because I could have sworn
the judge gave like an actual order here and we had order granting
in part. This right here granting in part governing discovery
plaintiff's motion to seal. Is it one of these two? It's one
of these two, isn't it? For miscellaneous relief. I thought I
thought the court actually commented on this, but I can't remember
which document it was in now. I haven't covered these in so long.
Did anyone remember which document it was in? Because I could
have sworn it was in one of these and I I literally can't find
it >> Was it on what? >> Uh just the ABMC like why
ABMC wasn't there. I could have sworn he they commented on why
ABMC was not testifying. I know the Rose thing. Yeah, I know
the Rose thing.
>> Right. This guy. Okay. As to plaintiff's allegations
that defendant transmitted the video to another individual ABMC
after the effect of data Cardi. Defendant argues that ABMC should
have testified at an earlier June 3rd 2025 hearing before the
court that touched on among other issues subject matter jurisdiction.
Defendant for his part leans on his declaration as to the date
formatting on the discord chat primarily issue plaintiff's mistake
as to discord chat. So it's basically arguing over the date of
the Rose messages and then document entry 42 at 14. But Mr. Banell's
declaration then states that based on information belief I have
not sent the video to anyone other than Rose. Certainly not sent
it to anybody else. And then they say dated April 9th, 2022.
So there's an argument over April or
April 9th or April 10th or October 10th or April 4th or October
4th or whatever. Right? It's the argument here.
Uh and for all of defendants protest that ABMC should have testified
at the hearing. Noticeably absent from defendants's arguments
generally regarding subject matter jurisdiction is testimony
from Rose that would corroborate defendants's characterization
of the Discord chat in his declaration. a characterization that
incorporates in exhibit C a screenshot from Rose's Discord account
that plaintiff could not have obtained on his own from his side
of the conversation. Thus, as it stands at this stage of the
case, the evidence purportedly establishing a definitive timeline
as to what defendant did or did not do and when is murky at best.
In any event and under the circumstances, we need not reach a
decision on jurisdiction today. Defective allegations of jurisdiction
may be amended upon terms in the trial or applet courts. Oh,
so they could just leave this until the trial as well. We've
got like audio stuff coming guys. It should be like a day or
two and we'll have like an actual audio set up so we can stream
in this room and it's going to work. Uh probably two days I think.
Okay. So plaintiff's motion is the result of undue delay. We
need not reach an answer to jurisdiction because even if plaintiff's
jurisdictional allegations were initially defective, the proper
course in the assistance instance would be to grant leave to
amend.
Okay. All right. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Cool. Okay. So we're
back to this guy. So, it's just like I it doesn't seem like they
needed her at that that date or at that court date. Despite the
council for plaintiff also represents ABMC and despite the plaintiff,
she wasn't testifying at the hearing. Accordingly, Banell had
no opportunity to ABMC or otherwise test the statements in her
declaration.
Is there a reason she would have had to testify here directly?
Like, is there a reason they wouldn't just wait until the court
date? Yeah, I know. We went over that Maximus. Yeah, we went
over that maximus like a hundred times when we first went over
all of these documents that the there's basically no difference
between an unsworn statement under penalty of perjury and a sworn
statement. On July 2nd, 2025, attorneys for Banell participated
in a telephonic meet and confer conference with plaintiffs council
Joan Peters. During that conference, Banell's lawyer explained
to Miss Peters the difficulties they encountered in trying to
serve her client ABMC with a subpoena issued on May 15th, 2025.
Videl's attorneys again inquired whether Miss Peters and her
co-consil still represented ABMC and whether they were authorized
to accept service of the subpoena on her behalf. Miss Peters
indicated that she would speak with her client and revert. Uh
having received no response from Miss Peters of her or her co-consel,
council for Benell emailed them a further inquiry on July 7th,
uh previously
referenced example paragraph 10 and exhibit F. On July 8th, 2025,
Miss Peters responded that she and her co-consil were not authorized
to accept service uh of the subpoena for ABMC. Accordingly, on
July 8th, 2025, Council for Benel requested ABMC's current contact
information. To date, neither Miss Peters nor her co-consel,
Mr. Garcia Perez, have responded to that request. Notwithstanding,
so I guess they don't have Abby as somebody they're representing
anymore, or they I don't know the legality of this. It seems
like it would be dodgy. I understand how somebody would feel
it's dodgy, right? To not be a not be willing to to get info
from this person, not be willing to hand any of that over. I
don't know what the legality is here, right? Yeah. I don't know.
Okay. So, notwithstanding Benell's inability to serve Oh, notwithstanding
Benell's inability to personally serve ABMC with the subpoena
and notwithstanding that Miss Peters and her co-consel continue
to refuse to accept service of the subpoena on their client's
behalf, ABMC has been well aware of the subpoena and the efforts
to save to serve her. Uh, example eight. On July 24th, 2025,
ABMC posted about the subpoena on her public account on the social
media platform X, noting that the subpoena had some random address
on it and she had not been served. ABMC has continued to comment
online and elsewhere about her knowledge of the subpoena and
suggested in at least one live streamed interview that her attorney
advised her to continue to evade service of the process and continue
to submit evidence. Uh, paragraph 12 and exhibit H. Specifically
on or about September 8th, 2025, ABMC participated in a live
stream interview with streamer known as Darius IRL. Paragraph
12 previously referenced paragraph 12. Among other things, ABMC
stated during this live stream, I am currently being subpoenaed
by Destiny. 45 seconds. I have seen the subpoena paperwork from
my lawyers, but he Banel has not been able to officially serve
me. Uh 3 minutes 36 and three. Because they send copies of it
first, their lawyers send my lawyers the information. 653. In
response to a question about what her attorneys advised her to
do, ABMC explained that they advised her to avoid it and avoid
Benel, avoid everything and keep submitting evidence. Yeah. Uh,
I don't know if her lawyer said that. I feel like that would
be weird to say, but again, I don't know what the legality is
here. So,
you think Darius was fishing for info at Destiny's direction?
This sounds like the interview she did with Darius. This is when?
July 12th. July 8th. Would that be two months ago? No, this is
way after the first interview she did with Darius.
yeah. I don't know why she would be saying this stuff, but as
you know, I just like to I just like to take Destiny's direction
here and say, listen, that wasn't said under any penalties in
any legal case. That was just said on a stream that doesn't mean
anything. Okay? Can we can we use that standard, guys, where
the stuff said on streams just doesn't mean anything. It can't
be held as truthful because it's not in the big boy setting of
a of a court case. Is that fair? I feel like that's
No, obviously if they're like, "Oh, just don't accept service.
Don't bother testifying. Just keep like keep submitting EV."
I don't know. Like to me, that would be odd. That doesn't feel
like fair. I would understand how that could feel unfair to somebody.
Obviously, remember when they muted it was obvious he was recording?
Yeah, I wouldn't trust Darius at all. I wouldn't trust Darius
to not give everything he hears to Destiny, right? Legal standard
rule 12b1 authorizes dismissal where the court lacks subject
matter jurisdiction. jurisdictional challenges may or be facial
or factual. Okay, this is just going to say that they're they're
based on a lack of subject matter jurisdiction. That's how they're
going for a motion to dismiss. Banel's sole transmission of the
video to Rose fails to establish subject matter jurisdiction
as a matter of law. So, there's going to be a couple things here.
He's going to submit his law his side of the DMs with Rose showing
that he showing that he sent these messages to clear up the timeline
to say this is April and not not October. Okay, that'll be number
one or October. Yeah, not October. That'll be number one. Number
two will be he's going to show his logs with Abby so that he
can say here's the stuff I sent Abby. Right. She just talked
to Darius again a week ago, right? I don't know. Sounds like
that would be a really bad idea, but hey, she's a free person.
Do whatever she wants. Plaintiff alleges the court has subject
matter jurisdiction because of her claims. Oh, sorry. Banell's
still transmission. Yeah. Plaintiff alleges the court has subject
matter jurisdiction because of her claims arise. Sorry. Because
her claims arise under the federal party statute.
Critically, Cardi took effect on October 1st, 2022, 15 USC 6851.
Cardi provides remedies for conduct occurring only as of the
effective date of the statute.
Oh, also one of the other pieces I think there's a third argument
they have, right? I wonder if this is addressed. There's the
the like continuing distribution thing, and that could possibly
end up being something they take to trial and they want like
a jury's input on, right? the continuing distribution thing like
the fact that he was posting that stuff. I don't believe that
would be the case. Like if I had to guess from the from the what
do you call it the precedence and stuff I would guess that continuing
distribution, you can't really argue that based on the the links
being Discord links that were perpetually available. Abby said
DG was sending death threats to her grandparents. Uh probably.
Yeah, I wouldn't be shocked.
Sounds like them. Sounds like a Destiny community thing to do.
See Glenra vah
holding a court must not give retroactive effect to statutes
burdening private rights unless Congress has made clear its intent.
No such legislative intent for retroactive application exists
here. Indeed, federal district courts have held that Cardi cannot
be applied retroactively to conduct predating the effective date
of the statute. Plaintiff sought to amend her complaint to add
a claim under Cardi for conduct allegedly occurring in March
and April 2022. Um in opposition the defendant asserted that
Cardi did not go into effect until April 1st 2022 or sorry October
1st 2022 and that because the newly alleged conduct occurred
prior to the state plaintiff's cardi claim could not m lie as
a matter of law. The court applied the holding in Langdorf and
denied plaintiff's motion. So it's basically saying that yes
you cannot do retroactive application of federal laws federal
civil actions. Okay.
Banel's sole transmission of the video to Rose preceded the effective
date of Cardi statute by nearly six months. Uh, this is this
is all the factual stuff, right? This is a factual legal standard.
Oh, so on the face of her first amended complaint, plaintiff
has not alleged that Benell transmitted the video to Rose after
Cardi went into effect. Instead, plaintiff retreats to ambiguity.
She alleges only that the video was sent sometime in 2022. Accompanied
by a footnote stating that it cannot be conclusively determined
whether the trans transmission to Rose occurred after a October
1st, 2022. Amitted complaint paragraph 12 number one.
Plaintiff's contentions are demonstrabably false. The evidentiary
record, including leaked Discord communications, which have long
been available to plaintiff, conclusively establishes that the
video was transmitted in April 2022, nearly 6 months before Cardi
took effect. The evidence shows that Rose's side of her communications
with Benel, was accessed and leaked by a third party with the
screen named Solo Tiny Leaks, who being located in Europe, downloaded
the messages. This is not true that they are This is not true
that they're located in >> or it's not conclusively true
in any way. Uh, rock surgeon, thank you for the five gifted.
Let's go. What is that? We're up to 18 gifted here on the stream.
Give me a second. Let me pull this up. I'll do this right now.
Was it 50
90 bucks? 95
bucks. We'll say that's 45 and 50. We'll go 1 hour 9 43. Okay,
let me reset meters here real quick. Okay, meters getting reset.
Thank you very much for the generous donations. Rock Surgeon
Venomous Villain and CD ROM. Thank you guys. Thank you. Okay,
we got all this stuff refreshed. We're good to go. Yes, we're
good to go. 25 like five gifted for another hour after that,
but listen, we're we're good to go. We're locked in. The evidential
record, including leaked Discord communications, which have long
been available to the plaintiff, conclusively establishes the
video was transmitted in April 2022, nearly 6 months before the
Cardi date took effect. So, the judge said, "Send me your side
of the logs cuz Rose's side of the logs indeterminate." It's
it's indeterminate. We don't know. The evidence shows that Rose's
side of her communication with Banell was accessed and leaked
by this guy located in Europe. Messages that the timestamps are
reflected in standard European.
Accordingly, the following leaked screenshot from Rose's correspondence
with Banel reflects that he transmitted the video to her on 104,
2022 or April 10th, 2022.
Okay. Indeed, a simple comparison of Rose's leaked screenshots
to Banell's side of the same communication, which was not leaked,
conclusively establishes that the video was transmitted on April
9th, 2022 at 8:36 p.m. Eastern. So, yes, this is April 9th, 2022.
Yep. Yep. The additional leaked correspondence between Rose and
Banell further confirms that Rose's communications are displayed
in the European date format. After Banell transmitted the video
to Rose in April 2022, the two continue to communicate on Discord
and those subsequent communications were also publicly posted
online by solo tiny leaks. For example, on April 14th, so this
is going to say that obviously if it goes beyond like it's 1404,
right?
Then that's pretty obvious that there's no 14th month. He's with
a minor here. He is with a minor here. Factually, yes, factually
correct. These are sex. This is him with a minor. Yep. That's
totally proven out. Unlucky. All right. The evidence thus confirms
the plaintiff cannot dispute that Banell transmitted the video
to Rose on a single occasion. Well, actually,
they can only prove he sent it to Rose on a single occasion.
Okay. He's not submitted his the entirety of his logs or the
entirety of everything he sent to them, right? Plaintiff's theory
of continuous ongoing disclosure fails as matter of law. Okay.
Okay, so this is the one where they'll have the precedence to
show that you you can't consider like a Google Drive link or
some some publicly, you know, some public URL that has some high
entropy string in it cannot be counted as
as like an openly accessible link. Okay. In an effort to evade
the fatality of her claim based on Card's effective date, plaintiff's
amended complaint reframes Banell's April 2022 transmission to
Rose as supposedly having occurred through a Google Drive link
and contends without any legal or factual support that such a
transmission somehow constitutes an ongoing dissemination or
continuous ongoing disclosure of the video, thereby establishing
subject matter jurisdiction.
Plaintiff's theory is contradicted by the evidence and in any
event fails as a matter of law. As an initial matter, there is
no evidence that Benell ever transmitted the video to Rose or
anyone else via Google Drive. Indeed, the leaked screenshot of
the transmission itself confirms that Banell sent the video to
Rose in a private Discord chat via Discord media file, not via
Google Drive link. So, they had an argument for this anyway.
It doesn't matter. It's kind of mood. The screenshot of Banell's
transmission of the video to Rose depicts a black square representing
a media file, not a Google Drive hyperlink. Banell declaration
uh from this declaration. Indeed, as evident from the November
2024 leak on Qi Farm's website, the original file name of the
video appears as vid
2410707
uh and then some other MP4, confirming that the video file was
transferred directly through Discord as an attached MP4 file
and not transmitted via Google Drive link. Critically, however,
even if the video had been shared via via Google Drive link,
plaintiffs theor legal theory fails as a matter of law. Courts
have rejected the proposition that privately shared unindexed
cloud links amount to public or continuous dissemination. In
Ray v Greenberg,
um the district court considered whether private material transmitted
via Google Drive link to a third party could constitute an ongoing
transmission of such material to the public. As here, the plaintiffs
in Ray asserted that the Google Drive link was configured so
it was viewable by anyone with a link and did not require a password
at 11. Uh oh, this is the reference. In rejecting plaintiff's
assertion, the court held that even assuming the link was public
and thus theoretically accessible to anyone, there are no facts
that suggest the link was in fact widely disseminated or placed
in a location where anyone could access it. 1115.
The court continued emailing a public link to a shared drive
to a single of a share drive to a single person is unlike publicizing
information in a regional magazine or newspaper.
Similarly, in the parallel case, Greenberg Vay.
So Greenberg, we'd have to look at these to see um what the allegations
were because again I don't know that this requires publishing
here does not mean like publishing in a regional magazine or
newspaper, right? This is a different terms of term of publishing.
Publishing is is like literally sending it to one person, right?
Making continuously available. Yeah. So I I think there's there's
probably some argument here that might need to be settled because
I don't think the disclosure standard here is necessarily the
same as publishing uh publicly like in a regional magazine or
newspaper.
We'll have to see. Similarly, in the parallel case Greenberg
v Ray, the court expanded on its reasoning as applied to a violation
of federal computer fraud statute 18USC section 1030G in Greenberg.
The court rejected the assertion that materials sent via Google
Drive can be considered a continuous distribution to the public.
Plaintiff acknowledges that the portion of the Google Drive was
not password protected, but plaintiff alleges that the setting
did not per se render the Google Drive public given that the
URL was a string of 68 characters. This is what I told you guys.
The precedent says that essentially like a UYU ID or a a string
a really high entropy string that's randomized is essentially
a password, right? That's a the link is the the link is a password.
So unless it's reshared, it's essentially like a password protected
thing. Nobody's going to guess that or randomly stumble upon
it. It has to be shared intentfully just the same way a file
would, which I think is the correct ruling to be honest with
you. But plaintiff alleges that this setting did not matter.
What's more, the Google Drive was not indexed by any search engines.
Therefore, it wasn't just anyone with a browser who could stumble
upon the Google Drive link on a web search. The internet denisine
wishing to access the Google Drive needed to obtain the exact
URL into the browser needed to type the exact URL into the browser.
By the court's eye, plaintiff alleges that the Google Drive had
limitations and thus persons attempting to access it needed authorization.
Uh here even if Biden's transmission of the video to Rose occurred
via Google Drive link, it did not. Such conduct could not. So
even if it was through a discord link, you were linking the file
that you'd sent. That is a randomly like created link. I think
that's the create or that's the correct precedence here. Queen
live with 100 viewers. Let's go.
Um let's see here. I think the issue here Maximus is if we apply
that standard retroactively, there's a whole bunch of that needs
to be done. There's a whole bunch of like there's basically so
many people who are liable for this exact conduct that like the
the ramifications the spidering out of ramifications from that
might be really [__] Like that might actually just
be too much for the courts to deal with. That would essentially
mean anybody who had sent non-consentually to anybody else, like
basically ever had a like a duty to go back through their old
accounts and delete it all, which probably wouldn't be bad, but
I'm just saying that like it's like those people are not good
people, but it's like that's a burden that's kind of
I don't know, it's kind of rough. Anyway, uh plaintiff's new
allegations regarding ABMC are not consistent with the evidence
and failed to establish subject matter jurisdiction. In her latest
attempt to manufacture subject matter jurisdiction, plaintiff
amended her complaint to allege that at some unspecified time
after March 2023, Banell sent the video to ABMC via Google Drive
link. Plaintiff's new allegations are not only unsupported, but
also directly contradicted by the evidentiary record. Moreover,
plaintiff's reliance on ABMC's testimony to establish subject
matter jurisdiction is particularly misplaced. ABMC has evaded
service of a subpoena, failing failed to volunteer for deposition,
and declined to appear or testify at the June 3rd, 2025 evidentiary
hearing. ABMC's refusal to produce evidence consistent with the
allegations is fatal the plaintiff's claims. Plaintiff cannot
meet her burden to establish subject matter jurisdiction and
the emotion should not be should be granted accordingly.
Uh a the evidence establishes that Benell did not transmit the
video to ABMC at any time. Plaintiff alleges that at some unspecified
time in March 20 after March 2023, Banell sent the video to ABMC
via Google Drive link and that ABMC recognized the plaintiff
in the video by her face and hair. Citted complaint paragraphs
14 to 15. The evidentiary record, however, flatly contradicts
these claims and confirms that Benell never transmitted the video
to ABMC. So, this is like it's saying the evidentiary record.
I think I think what they're saying is the evidentiary record
we're about to to submit cuz obviously this was not a part of
the evidentiary record in any way,
right? So I think they're saying the evidentiary record we will
henceforth submit is what's actually going to prove this out.
I assume
nor has plaintiff produced any evidence to the contrary. To be
clear, plaintiff bears the burden to prove the facts sufficient
to establish subject matter jurisdiction. Big Le League Ventures
dismissing the action for lack of subject matter jurisdiction
pursuant to 12B1. This is added. Sure. Here plaintiff cannot
meet her burden because the evidence demonstrates just the opposite
of what she alleges in her amended complaint.
But preserve communication logs. Oh, so it is his stuff. So I
don't think they even subpoenaed her for a deposition. They're
arguing they tried to latigious Gamer and they're saying they
produced um they're saying they're showing emails where they've
asked her council to accept service on behalf of her or to provide
some updated address and they refused to or failed to. So like
I'm not sure how that goes exactly. But it feels like that's
probably not great, but I'm not totally sure. I'm not sure what
I'm not sure what burden they have to accept service for a plaintiff
they're representing somewhere else. Like the subpoena they submitted
is not for a deposition. It's for production of documents. Oh,
okay.
Interesting. Very interesting. So, Vanell's preserved. I think
this is interesting to me that it's like I have I downloaded
my logs and I I downloaded my logs in in an editable format and
they showed that I didn't send that video to her at all and she's
already said that she doesn't have my side of the logs.
Okay, that's a
Okay. Bell's preserved communication logs with ABMC conclusively
established that he never transmitted the video to her at any
time. See Banell declaration paragraphs 7 to8 and exhibit E.
These logs capture every media file Benell ever transmitted to
ABMC and none contained the video depicting plaintiff. Um paragraph
8 in the previously referenced document and ex exhibit E. The
original file name of the video vid 242401
I was revealed when solo so are they going to argue that this
is the only possible file name this could be under and that the
file name sent don't correspond with it?
That's huh. Isn't Pixie's team obligated to give Aby's contact
at least? I I would think they have to pass service along but
I have no idea.
I have no idea if that's true.
And like to me in terms of fairness, yeah, I feel like that absolutely
should happen, right? But I don't know what's legally obligated
there and what like trickery they might be going with. Like I
don't know what they're trying to do. Like it feels wrong to
me if they're allowed to not pass it on. So,
but I also feel like if is the argument going to be uh file names
don't match, so this wasn't set because that seems a little odd
to me. Anyway, uh the original file name of the video, so file
name was revealed when Solo Tiny Leaks uploaded it to the Kiwi
Farms website without authorization. Exhibit D. By contrast,
the files been sent to ABMC bear entirely different file names,
none of which correspond to the file name of Plaintiff's video.
Further, each of the media files been sent to ABMC contain embedded
date stamps indicating the date on which the original file was
created. For example, spoiler pixel 2023.
Uh, so March 2023.
See this is added. These date time date stamped file names confirm
that each of the media files that Benell sent to ABMC were created
in 2023 unlike the videos depicting plaintiff which by plaintiff's
own sworn testimony were created in 2020. So I don't know I don't
actually know if this is true if like I I would imagine this
is a video shot on a pixel, right? EXL
that seems like it makes sense. I think they would be under rule
26A1
A1 assuming they were aware of the info. I wonder if they are
aware of the info. Like I wonder if they're aware of more than
So I guess the question would be coming down to the exhibits
if they had like an email address or like a Discord name for
Abby
and they refused to give that even. I feel like that would seem
weird to me. You know what I'm saying? But then Darius had a
phone number for her too. Like Darius got called by her. So I
don't know. It's
It's all strange to be honest with you. Okay.
Depicting uh the evidence also establishes that Banell did not
transmit the video to AB the video to ABMC via Google Drive.
Banell said ABMC only two Google Drive links on November 3rd,
2023. Cenel declaration dated September 19th, 2025, paragraph
9 and exhibit F. E. Contents of those links
uh contain contain videos of Benell with another woman who uses
the screen name Peach and they do not depict the plaintiff. Uh,
paragraph nine. In fact, Peach herself confirmed that these same
files bearing the same unique Google Drive URLs that Banell sent
to ABMC depicted her and not plaintiff exclaiming, "Oh my god,
awe, that's me." in contemporaneous communications with Banell.
Okay, I I
really hope this makes it to trial, okay? Cuz I just want I want
Baby Peach to have to testify on behalf of Destiny. Okay, that's
like my ideal world where I I get a world where I get to read
testimony from Baby Peach in court. Okay, that's like
let's go. That would be amazing. All right,
so in those same communications, Peach consented to and even
encouraged further sharing of her video exhibit F. You can also
add the video to my resume if you have any single friends. Gross.
Notably, on or around September 5th, 2023, Abby visited Benell
at his home. Uh, previous reference paragraph 10. Sometime that
afternoon, Bedell temporarily left his home and printed permitted
AbbyMC to stay there while she waited for her flight that evening.
Unbeknownst to Bedell at the time, Abby began snooping around
his house in studio, taking videos and photographs of his possessions.
She then sent a photograph of Banell's desktop computer to her
friend Darius with the messages, "Major leaks prob."
Without Banell's knowledge, ABMC had access to his computer and
was able to priv view private files directly from his desktop.
To the extent ABMC claims to have seen the video depicting plaintiff,
she could only have done so while snooping through Benell's computer,
not because Benell ever transmitted the video to her. The ABMC
declaration and accompanying exhibit failed to support, let alone
improve subject matter jurisdiction. You probably coach. Yeah,
who knows? Um, no shot there going with the skitso theories.
I don't know how this will work, right? I don't know how this
will shake out cuz realistically, like these are all editable
files that he's submitting. Um, he'd be it'd be insane to actually
edit this stuff because I think you would be beyond
if if let's say for some reason Discord was holding on to your
data and you Discord was subpoenaed that data came back and it
showed that you had like modified anything you've submitted to
the court. I think you're like I think you're beyond in that
case at least for for this stuff, right? All this document is
discussing are facts that need to be determined by a jury.
That's the thing is I don't know if the judge would actually
rule that this is finalized and I don't know that he would like
we'll see I guess but like I do think a lot of this stuff would
have to be placed in front of a jury and they would need subject
matter experts. No judge is going to be able to rule on whether
or not like even these allegations are correct, right? Like he's
going to go, "Oh, this could this be changed? Oh, could the the
file be like renamed somewhere at JTO Destiny said he was modifying
the times." Oh, no. He he didn't say somewhere publicly that
he modified some of these logs he saved, did he? That would not
be smart. Can you link that to me, Kendrick? He must see this
motion has a very low chance of success, but backing out now
puts him in a terrible position for settlement negotiations.
Sure. Okay. Well, anyway, keeping keeping it moon, keeping it
pushing. The evidence also establishes Bedell did not transmit
the video via Google Drive Peachly on around September. Oh, this
is a snooping thing. Okay. The ABMC declaration and accompanying
exhibit failed to sport, let alone prove subject matter jurisdiction.
Plaintiff contends that ABMC declaration establishes that the
video is transmitted to ABMC, but it does no such thing. Instead
of providing evidence of the alleged transmission, i.e. a screenshot
of the message in which Benell supposedly sent the video to ABMC.
Plato relies on a single self-s serving text message from ABMC
to an unknown third party dated November 3rd, 2023 where an ABMC
writes, I have videos of him, these other people, LMFAO, he just
sent me another one. Haven't opened it. Docket 861. This unauthenticated
exhibit does not come close to establishing that Banell transmitted
the video of the plaintiff at all, let alone that he transmitted
the video at any time after the effective date of the Cardi statute.
Oh, so the argument here that they're kind of ignoring is they
didn't know each other until after the Cardi statute came out
and she figured it out somehow, right? And she's claiming that
he sent it. So, I'm guessing this will just it'll come down to
like how the court views it, right? Like they might say, "Hey,
we haven't gotten our subpoenas back from Discord yet. We want
to know if we got any of this stuff. We want to see if we'll
have any record of this conversation."
Right? So, so where yeah, this unauthenticated exhibit does not
So, this is the thing. this unauthenticated exhibit. Where has
any of the stuff been authenticated? They've not prevented or
provided any authenticated exhibit either. Right? As far as I've
seen,
this unauthenticated exhibit does not come close to establishing
that Benell transmitted the video of the plaintiff at all, let
alone that he transmitted the video at any time after the effective
date of the Cardi statute. Plaintiff could have submitted proof
of such a transmission. Yet, she has not done so. And for good
reason, it never happened. At most, the Profit ABMC declaration,
an accompanying exhibit, constitutes inadmissible hearsay, i.e.
An out of court statement prove offered to prove that Benell
transmitted a video of plaintiff after the Cardi statute went
to effect. Wait, it's direct testimony though. It's literally
just direct testimony. ABMC does not submit any actual evidence
of such transmission, but instead submits a text message that
she sent wherein she claims she received a video of plaintiff
from an unknown person at an unknown time. The IBMC declaration
and accompanying exhibit should be disregarded accordingly.
ABMC refuses to comply with subpoena and plaintiff's council
refuses to provide contact information for their star witness
when uh while plaintiff's sole remaining basis for subject matter
jurisdiction relies on the uncorroborated and untested declaration
of ABMC ECF number 49 or yeah no 492 plaintiff and her council
allegedly have obstructed Banell's access to their star witness
for nearly 5 months
depriving Benell of the opportunity to ABMC about the false statements
in her declaration and other public statements she has made about
Banell and this lawsuit. Despite that, ABMC is on notice and
of and in possession of the subpoena. She continues to dodge
service and failed to appear to testify at the June 3rd, 2025
evidentiary hearing. As ABMC continues to evade service, she
has commented online and elsewhere about being aware of the subpoena
and recently suggested in a live stream on September 8th, 2025
that her attorneys advised her to continue to evade service of
uh service of process evade service of process brother declaration
dated September 19th and exhibit H. Specifically, on her about
September 8th, 2025, ABMC participated in a live stream of streamer
Darius IRL, wherein she stated her her attorneys advised her
to continue to evade service of the of process and continue to
submit evidence. The date here is different. This was July 7th
before. Now it's September 8th.
>> Hold on. Let's see. Let's check out some of this stuff.
>> You sent me this. This is a clip of What is this?
Go on the [__] the lamest. Okay, this is None of
this matters. No one cares. Okay. But I figured this out last
night. Finally. Okay. All right.
This is just random complaining. Okay. Go on the the lamest.
Okay. This is none of this matters. No one cares. Okay. But this
is
You sent me this in DMs. What is this? So, it's just to get a
time stamp. Click full foot. Watch full. Okay. Okay.
>> This is just random complaining. Okay. >> I got
you. I got you. that you can talk about when it comes to time.
Complicated
thing. Okay, there's a lot of different things that you can talk
about when it comes to time. What time is it? Who knows what
time earlier? What time was it? What time was it with respect
to who? Okay, fine might have relativity and all this frame of
reference and whatever other culture time. There might be there
might be daylight savings time. There could be time zone swaps
that could happen. You have no idea. Okay, so computers have
this.
>> What did you really clip this before he did his whole
You couldn't have clipped this after he did his stupid little
thing this nifty little thing called >> I'm sorry. I actually
appreciate the time stamp. Thank you. >> All right. And
then what computer, >> sorry, I just don't want to listen
to >> It says, "Okay, well, there's some date I think 1970,
January 1st or something, and we're just going to count up from
here in seconds." Okay, I was like, "Okay, that makes sense,
I guess." So, you'll see these like Unix time codes that will
be um yeah, you know, like I don't know anywhere from 8 to 12
digits how many zeros up. >> So, for purposes of presentation
to legal teams or whatever, okay, I can't be shoving a whole
bunch of, you know, wacky JSON or CSV files or just like crazy.
It's just not readable person. Even in a spreadsheet, it looks
like people want nice cute HTML CSS formatted things that look
like, oh, this like looks like a thing can read.
So the issues that I have have two different things. Okay. I
have a discord chat that I can export logs from >> and
then I have archives from our program called redacted. Okay.
Now both of these output time in different ways. But that's okay
because I should be able to commence. The goal is I need to take
the redacted archive and my discord export and I just need to
merge them to create a synthetic file that combine both sets
of data and then I can search chronologically and it should look
like the reassembled original conversation. Right. Easy. That's
easy, right? No. No problem. No problem. Well, so what we do,
Discord outputs in
um a program called Discord chat explorer I think and I can set
it to output in UT equals Z. Okay, and then I have a um thing
called redacted and outputs in Unix time. Okay, easy. So all
we have to do is take all of these timestamps. Okay, so export
I guess bring you know spreadsheet all of these timestamps um
for whatever UT plus 0 convert all of them in a batch operation
to Unix time and then combine these two data sets and then sort
chronologically and then I can take the time and then revert
all back to human time. Okay, easy, right? Easy. Not easy.
>> Synthetic file. I mean, this is all like easy to do.
The issue is like it's all modifiable very easily, right? Very
easily just take a line out anywhere you want. Does he understand
what he's saying in public? Um, he's not claiming to have like
modified anything here yet. He's saying he's taking these things
to put it together so somebody can read it and that he would
have the underlying like evidence here. He's not saying what
you think he's saying. I don't know why, but nothing is lighting
up. And I'm spending too much time, hours trying to figure out
why. There's chunks of messages up and down and and it's just
not. And the short story is like four hours of [__]
sorting through this. I finally figured out I'm like, "Hold on,
I can't really do this dumb." And then I start comparing the
time stamps. Like, why does it be like her talking for this chunk
and then me talking like we're not talking to each other and
like, "Wait a second." But sometimes it lines up, but sometimes
it doesn't. And so I check the dates on what lines up and I check
the date what doesn't line up. >> Yeah, it's picking the
date and it's feeding things into a date. And yeah,
dude, it's it's crazy trying to deal with time stamp stuff. >> And
I realized, okay, after too many hours that >> like sometimes
it'll do like 11:00 p.m. on this day and it won't actually if
you if that when you switch the time zones actually switches
like the the date over to a different day, it won't overflow
the date correctly. It won't go into the next day. It'll just
stay on the same day and like restart the time. >> Feel
like saving time is applied to like 75% of the log over here
and not over here. Oh yeah, that's also that's also going to
get you. >> So I have to >> it should just be sorting
by the Unix time stamp only. >> Oh once I know the problem
it's easy because then I just take this you can take the units
time. You can do a calculation for how much you need to subtract
for daily savings time. And then on the spreadsheet I can subtract
and get 14,400 for the full EST and then there's like whatever
I don't remember the thing you can include in the spreadsheet
and I can do the formula on just the daily savings time dates
to remove that much time from that to change the unit time stamps
and then merge the data sets and I merged them and I clicked
the sort alphabetically and then and then all of it worked. It
was like 6 a.m. by the time I finished creating this. Oh my god.
Holy [__] I don't know why. Wait, the Unix time stamps
shouldn't change based on um daylight savings time. The Unix
time stamps are in UTC and they get they get translated after
the the the UTC time stamps should not they're just they're literally
the Unix time stamps are just UTC
and then you do the translation after. It shouldn't matter whether
one's in daylight savings or the other, right? That's the Unix
time stamps should sort perfectly no matter what time zone they're
sent from. No matter what >> it I don't understand if some
people what what I'm not sure happened and maybe I'm just missing
something. So I'm I think I should say I'm not understanding
cuz what I think happened can't really be this stupid. Okay.
What I think happened can't really be this stupid. Okay. If if
a doctor tells you that you need to eat this much medication,
right? You know that like these things are not the same, right?
You can't these two things are not I don't right. If something
tells you you know 4.00 then your tolerance for error is like
you could have um
um what is it? This can be up to four or
[__] I don't remember three point. [__]
It could be that, right? Who the [__] knows? This
could be, right? It could be. Could be that. [__]
It could be. [__] It could be that, right? Who [__]
knows, right? Cuz you're object, right? What I think might have
happened was maybe
cuz I feel like one of these programs didn't actually record
the time stamps at Unix time. It just did like a back conversion
from the date listed to Unix time and pretended like that was
a Unix time code, I think. But that's not Unix time code because
that could be something to a whole bunch of other weird [__]
like daylight savings time. Maybe. I don't know if they did.
I would hope nothing would that's really weird. My imagination
would be that everything would use Unix time and it would only
be like a front end um like a like um I don't know I don't know
terms but like the user would but the um the underlying time
I don't know oh my [__] god
display string probably okay I understand like the the problem
but um he's not like he's not really saying what you guys think
he's saying but it also is just showing unfortunately it shows
that like how obvious
right it shows how obvious it is that he's able to modify whatever
he wants out of these files, but he's not he's not saying like,
"Oh, I edited stuff maliciously and there would be like the base
files he'd have them output to, but unfortunately like
it's just easily
and there's every reason for him to not be truthful with it."
So,
I don't know. I don't know how that plays out in court. I don't
know how they treat that, right? I I actually don't know.
You trying to sound smart or something? I mean, I don't know.
I can't tell you.
almost always. But I wanted to go to this. Hold on. This is the
Darius thing. Give me a second. What are we looking for? We're
looking for the Breler.
Breler exhibit H. Exhibit H for Breler. Download PDF. Submitted.
Oh, to be submitted upon. I mean, it's a Darius stream from when?
Honestly, somebody could probably find this. It's apparently
a Darius stream from September 9th. That should be on his kick
page still, right? I would imagine. I can look for it after.
We'll just we'll we'll go look for it after. Plaintiff or council
should not be rewarded for obstructing Bedell's access to ABMC,
an individual they identified in their rule 26A initial disclosures.
Oh, I do actually want to go through the Breler thing though
because with the with the Breler thing, I want to look at these
emails and see what they asked for, what they served, and all
of this. So, hold on. Let's go through these documents. So, Andrew
Breler, dear Mr. Bettler, I'm writing to you with regards to
my client ABMC specifically pertaining to your client Steven
Benell.
And then they redact all the rest of it. The rest of this, by
the way, is saying Destiny sent Vabby. Like, this is literally
something she's publicly alleged, right? Kick deletes the stream
after a month. It says it's on September 8th. So, that is 11
days ago. Perfectly
Anyway, that's the what the rest of this says. Okay. Exhibit
B, unsworn statement under penalty of perjury. This is the ABMC
stuff. Um, yeah. Okay. Under penalty of perjury.
Exhibit C. So, these are emails right here. May 14th, 2025. We
intend to serve a subpoena on your client, Abby MC. In the above
reference action, please let us know whether you are authorized
to accept service on her behalf. Exhibit D. Council, having not
heard back from you, pursuant to rule 454, attaches a copy of
a subpoena that will be served to on Ms. MC. Sincerely, Andrew
Breler. So, there's a subpoena.
This subpoena is is this the subpoena? It's not the subpoena.
Oh, this is the
to produce documents, information and or objects or to permit
inspection on premises of premises in a civil action. Recommended
to produce at the time, date and place set forth here uh below
the following documents electronically stored information or
objects or to permit inspection, copy and testing or sampling
of the material. One, all communications with the following individuals
regarding Steven Bedell. There's a bunch of people here. Ah,
there's a bunch of people here. So, produce these documents.
Um, so it's just for documents. It's literally not They're not
asking to depose her. They're not asking to question her. They're
not asking to have her testify. They've not attempted to serve
that as far as I could tell,
right? I I can't see any evidence that they attempted to serve
this person with with a deposition, with a subpoena to depose
her. They they don't want to depose her. They've been asked to
ask her questions. They've just said, "Can we can you give us
your Discord logs for your communications with these people?"
Brianna Woo apparently. Damn. All electronic correspondents you
exchanged with Benell. Okay, so they're just looking for communications.
The Abbey call timestamped. Okay. I mean, I'm probably just going
to look for the specific parts that are looked for, but I think
he has timestamps. I'll go look for them in a second. We can
go through it. Absolutely nothing. Oh my god, Pixie is actually
cooked. Lol. I'm working on submitting all the evidence I have
to also aid other victims and prevent these behaviors in the
future. Working on getting that subpoena from Desty's team, or
are you still dodging that? He just put some random address.
XD admitted saying you have knowledge of trying to be subpoenaed,
right? Consider this chat GBT stuff I just looked up. Aware of
the contents, the argument that you didn't receive it properly
might be less effective if you were aware of it and chose to
disregard it. Okay. Okay. So, this doesn't say it affects Pixie's
case. I don't know. She should probably add the service, but
interesting. Have you considered what Chachi Pedro just said
about this? Have you considered that, Abby? July 7th. July 6th.
Okay, we got bottom to top action going on here. Okay,
Joan Peters. Dear council, our deadline to file motions to join
additional parties and or amend the complaint is July 6th, 2025.
See docket 23, actually the 7th because the 6th is a Sunday.
This deadline was agreed to based on the prior deadline of June
4th for the exchange of written discovery responses. As you know,
we agreed to extend the June 4th deadline until 3 days after
the court rules on plaintiff's motion for protective order governing
discovery. The decision of adding parties or amending the complaint
is not fully informed without having received written discovery
responses. Thus, I propose asking the court to reset the July
6th deadline until 1 month after the court rules on the motion
for protective order governing discovery. Please advise if you
agree with this proposal and I will circulate a draft motion
or a draft circulate a draft joint motion. Thanks, Joan. Thanks,
Joan. Why don't we discuss by phone? What is your schedule like
for a brief call this week? I'm available tomorrow between noon
and 4:30 p.m. Eastern. Let me know if you have availability.
How's 1 p.m. Eastern uh daylight time or 11:00 a.m. PDT tomorrow?
Uh, that works. Can you please recirculate your dial and number?
Why would you give that an Andrew? Why? Oh, Jake Chimera. Okay,
Jake's got him. Uh, council, we are discussing, we're seeking
to amend the complaint pursuant to federal rules of civil procedure
1582 and 28 USC 1653 to include the allegations of defendants
sharing the video to ABMC. These allegations go to jurisdiction
under Cardi. Please, or sorry, per rule 15. Are you willing to
provide defendants written consent to amend the pleading? If
not, please consider this our attempt to meet and confer as required
by the local rules. If defendant is not willing to consent as
per rule 15, would defendant agree to not oppose a motion to
amend? Thanks, Joan.
Uh, dear Joan, we will oppose any motion to amend. You told me
you would get back to me on whether you author you are authorized
to accept a service for of a subpoena for ABMC. Yet, we've not
heard from you. Do you and Carlos still represent her? Sincerely,
Andrew. Uh, hi Andrew. I apologize for the delay in responding.
We are not authorized to accept service for the subpoena of ABMC.
Regards, Joan. Okay. So, nothing I literally nothing wrong up
until July 8th, it seems like. Right.
Okay. We go all the way down here. Uh, so this is the same stuff
here.
These are the exact same emails. It seems like
>> if you no longer represent her, okay, so if you no longer
represent her, please provide her pre provide us with her current
contact details. Thank you. Exhibit G.
So I think he says if I'm not mistaken do they say that they
get nothing else exhibit H and then it's a different thing. So
hold on
>> refuse to provide ABMC's current contact information
exhibit G as required per this federal rules of super procedure
so should not be rewarded. So hold on. >> Vade service.
Vade service.
>> Priving banel. This this this despite that ABMC.
>> I'm just looking for so I've refused to accept service
on behalf of ABMC.
They said they're not authorized. And
>> party must provide name, address, telephone number of
each individual likely to have discoverable information.
Okay. So there are rules of civil procedure. You have to provide
this. You have to have these things. If they have discoverable
information, you're aware of them. So, I'm guessing eventually
a judge, and it's possible a judge might say, "Hey, unless you
can get them this information, you should you should be able
to you shouldn't be able to use their testimony, right? Unless
you have this information on them, you have no way to talk to
them." Like, it seems like that would be quite bad. Okay, so
they're arguing a plaintiff in her council should not be rewarded
for obstructing Banell's access to ABMC, an individual they identified
in their 26A disclosures, initial disclosures. Council for plaintiff
and ABMC have refused to accept service on behalf of ABMC.
Refuse to provide ABMC's current contact information as required
under the federal rules of civil procedure.
um requiring supplementation in a timely manner if the party
learns that in some material respect the disclosure or response
is incomplete or incorrect and if the additional or corrective
information has not otherwise been made known. ABMC's uncorroborated
and untested declaration should be disregarded accordingly. C
Brown BNCL Bahamas Limited plaintiff's failure to comply with
rule 26A and E is grounds for exclusion under rule 37C.
So I think this could be true but I think they'd probably say
okay we're actually saying you have to go and uh like share this
information, right? Seems that way. It seems about that way.
>> Jesus. Okay.
So, six. The court should not exercise supplemental jurisdiction
over plaintiffs remaining state law claims. I am going to just
agree with this that they're a federal court and there's probably
no reason for them to conclude or continue with the state law
claims if they find no subject matter jurisdiction.
Um, that's what I've seen every lawyer say. So, I don't even
care about this paragraph. I just say, "Yeah, probably." Like
if you lose federal subject matter jurisdiction, I don't think
the court hears the state tor claims. That doesn't make any sense
to me.
The judge will ask if there's a reason and if not, just make
them hand it over. I'm guessing feels like Aby's getting cold
feet. Um I have no idea if that's true. In fact, it it seems
like that's not the case. Black Irish, it feels like the opposite.
Like explicitly the opposite
that she's like actually and like trying to say, "No, they told
me to dodge this." She's like taunting people. seems like the
opposite to me. But I don't know. Uh it's also just stupid to
taunt people to talk about your court case at all. It's just
always stupid to talk about your court case. I somehow in this
entire space Darius IRL is the only person who learned, hey,
maybe I should shut the up about my court case. I don't understand
how that's possible. Okay. I I legitimately I don't think since
since Darius got [__] over in that one in that thing
where he filmed, I don't think I've heard him talk about his
court case. Has he been talking about it? I think how is that
how is he the how does he have more self-control than Destiny
is wild. So you're saying 6 hours 4 minutes 40 seconds.
>> It's hurting his
>> Okay. So what are they saying for you to do? Just avoid
it or give him your
>> So you stopped getting subpoenaed. >> Avoid it.
>> Because they send me copies? >> If he's trying
to serve you cuz he would like to have the address that you're
staying at to serve papers. Do you think >> so? It sounds
like he Yeah, he So he did that for legally. no reason and tried
to find my baking location to find my >> To be fair, you
did wrong.
>> If he did, my lawyers would tell me. >> Why would
your lawyers tell you if you you need to accept papers that he's
trying to serve you?
>> Because they send me copies of it for >> they
send you >> Why would Abby say all this in public?
I dude, I don't know. I don't know why she would talk about this
in public. I don't know if any of this is true, by the way. She
could just be saying this.
All right. So, like, and I I don't really It's not my position
to like, how should I put this? She's talked about like other
her lawyers are helping her with. And I don't know what lawyers
she's talking about. I I literally have like no idea. Okay. I
don't know what's I don't know what she's talking about here.
I It seems like she's talking about the Pixie people, but their
lawyer said my lawyers trying to serve you. I thought you said
you saw them already cuz they were sent to your childhood address.
Yes, I can see them because my lawyers see it. >> So, they
did try to give it to you. >> I don't get officially sued.
>> You're just like you're poor and >> So, what are
they saying for you to do? Just avoid it or give him your address
so he stops getting subpoenaed. >> Avoid it and avoid him?
Avoid everything? Avoid everything and keep submitting evidence.
>> Why do you think your lawyers are telling you to avoid
getting served? Because it's a smart thing >> to protect
my case. Yes, it's a smart thing for everyone in this situation.
>> Okay. So, do you think that's like uh like a bad thing
that he's doing that then if it's if it's going to hurt your
>> It's almost like people are trying to hold you accountable
for the lies you >> Easy. Don't drink yourself to death.
>> Probably shouldn't be talking to Darius. No, but
>> it's hurting his credibility as a human being that he's
subpoenaing a victim's GoFundMe account that has nothing to do
with him. Hey,
>> so you're just like >> not in my banking information.
>> What do you mean? Why? Does that not say itself in a
sentence? >> I know you have low IQ, but >> No, cuz
it sounds like I just told you why you would do that. My My understanding
is because he would want to get your address. >> Yeah,
you're So you don't think that's nefarious at all? You just don't.
You just don't think he's trying
if he's trying to serve you. >> Not if he's trying to get
my address. Not if he's trying to find out where I live. Not
if he's trying to die. If he's trying to dox you, I understand.
But it doesn't sound like he's trying to dox >> Like he
has been like I mean like a lot of people have been still. >> Sounds
like he's trying to serve you papers. Why doesn't everyone just
subpoena you then all the time if everyone's trying to do it
so much? >> I don't know what that means. >> No way.
You went the wrong way. You went the truck way. >> Oh,
whoops. >> I get comments every day that my phone's being
watched and I I talk to my like you know systems animals and
I call them like specific names and I get comments um about that
guy. I've been on Discord calls where my phone was completely
muted like from my settings and my iPhone settings and people
have still heard me
>> to ask if you could >> and this is also recorded.
>> Would you be happy to forward this invitation but your
>> I don't know who is doing this to my I don't know that
is why the FBI is taking >> All this stuff is happening.
Don't you think you already have your address? >> You need
gas? >> Yeah. Any pizza?
>> Yeah, potentially. So that's why I'm waiting. If anyone
would like to come and serve me, they can. >> Wait, does
Hold on. I'd just like to point out again that the actual like
service they've they've provided is for documents. It's not for
testimony on anything she said. It's not to test subject matter
jurisdiction. I'm sure that like Pixie's legal team will talk
about that, right?
Like the service the the thing that the subpoena they actually
filed is not for a deposition. It's not to test her statements.
It's not to test subject matter jurisdiction. It is just for
service. It's just for discovery documents.
Like that. It's actually insane that they would say, "Oh, well,
we couldn't serve this, so actually we Yeah, I don't know. I
don't know, bro. Abby said they never asked her to testify in
person or whatever." Nobody has asked her to testify in person.
She has to be asked >> My lawyers are updated and I text
them frequently. So, >> I would just leave the car at the
pump.
>> Uh oh. Yeah. I'm
>> Give me one moment. I'm sorry. >> Chi's got to
pee also. Yeah. >> Oh, GC. You heard what I mean? >> Thought
it was Desi trying to serve her, but I could be wrong. Uh, yeah,
Destiny's trying to serve her, but it's the subpoena we looked
at is not a subpoena for a deposition. It's a subpoena for documents.
It's like a discovery subpoena to say, "Hey, I want your Discord
logs." You think it's an issue that Pixie's team is still in
contact with Abby, but they said do not they do not represent
her? No. But I do think that it's probably it's very likely that
they would have to give any information they have for contacting
her to Destiny's team, right? Like I I think that's absolutely
true that they'd have to do that at some point. But I don't I
don't think they necessarily have to say like, "Oh, we provided
service to her or something if they don't represent her, if they're
not authorized to to accept service for her." But I'd say if
they're communicating with her somehow, they should probably
have to reveal that to the court and say like, "This is how we're
communicating with her." Did they say they didn't represent her,
though? I thought they said they only they aren't authorized
to accept service. They said they aren't authorized to accept
Yes. Where is this here? It's uh D.
We are not authorized to accept service of the subpoena for AbbyMC.
I assume that means you do not represent her. Is can you have
lawyers who represent you but aren't authorized to accept service
on your behalf? I would assume that's like not legally allowed.
Excuse me. In like federal legal cases like I assume there'd
be some some civil procedure rule that says if if your lawyer
is representing you, they can accept service on your behalf,
right?
But I don't think that they actually have filed that case yet.
So they don't legally they might not be legally representing
her representing her in that case, right? Like that case isn't
filed yet as far as I know.
>> Clients have to give permission to accept service. Oh
well then, but I do think it seems pretty clear under the federal
rules of civil procedure. They have to give the the information
for contacting Abby to Destiny's team. And then I think if if
she can't be contacted, I think there is like a reasonable expectation
that they could throw that testimony out, right? If they're unable
to talk contact her at all, if they're unable to to depose her,
to subpoena her, to do anything there, I would imagine that's
like I would imagine that's a big deal, but I don't
I the one thing I don't know for sure is if there's a demand
or requirement that that be tested um before the court case kicks
off or if that would be something they test in court, >> right?
I don't know the line there where it's like, okay, this is something
we need a like a jury to look at. So that that seems
I guess like yeah, I just don't know. I'm not a lawyer, so that
would be interesting to look at some lawyer cover this stuff
and see where that line is. They had like two to three months
to give the contact to Andy. They did, but it seems like they've
like both sides have been total to each other, right? Like it
seems like both sides are being straight up and forcing the judge
to make them play like normal nice kids. Uh like if they had
two to three months to give the content, Andy, I don't know why
they wouldn't do that cuz they're being pricks. Cuz they're they're
going like, "Hey, you leaked our private meet and confer details.
You leaked like our private negotiations from before this. Go
yourself. Get a judge to order us to do it. Go yourself." is
like what they're doing through lawyer speak, right?
Like walk off a bridge. Good luck. I I that seems to be what's
happening to me. But is there some cynical angle? We're dragging
their feet. Um what do you mean cynical angle? This does help
Pixie, right? Like I would say probably to me you don't think
Aby's going to be somebody you want to have deposed. And I don't
know if the court is going to say no, no, no. We're not going
to decide we're we're going to like I think there's probably
some hope that the court will decide that they test these things
at trial, right? Like strategically, you might think that you
Aby's reliable, but that she's sorry, not reliable, that her
evidence is is true that she says like this is how I found out
about this, but that you think she would have a hard time getting
through a deposition with Andrew Brettler, right? So, you don't
want her to get deposed by Andrew Breler, for example. You want
that to be to happen at trial when you had time to prepare when
there's a bunch of other stuff going on, right? Or when you've
had more time, like time to go through discovery documents and
so either side wants her speaking. Sure.
I'm just saying that that might be their goal, right? Is like
we just want this decided at trial. Like we want time to prepare.
We want we want to not have to get um
we want not have to get bogged down in like trying to support
this person before we're going to trial. And I think that's like
what it would be. The the thing about this one versus a lot of
the other ones is with this one, I actually don't know what can
be decided by a judge or has to be decided by subject matter
experts because I could understand that this is the stuff being
laid out, right, by Destiny's team by But I think if Pixie's
team just like
I I this seems kind of to people who are technologically technologically
literate, right? But I think Pixie's team can basically go to
a bunch of the stuff that's in this motion and they could say
we don't know that. Like even on the time stamps, they could
go, "We don't know that. We need a tech expert to look at it.
We'll do that at trial. We don't know that. We don't know that.
We don't know that." Right? So almost everything around the Discord
timestamps, I think they can consistently go, "We don't know
that. We don't know that. We don't know that. We need an expert.
We need an expert. We need an expert." I think they could just
do that like for a lot of this stuff. And they can say, "Oh,
even the file name thing, we don't know that that proves anything.
We need an expert. We don't know anything about that file name.
We need an expert. We're waiting to to get the actual unadultered
logs from Discord, right? Like I I think they can do a lot of
that and I think the judge has already shown a proclivity to
go I don't think this is clear. I don't think we know this for
sure. Right? So, we'll see. I don't know what could be provided
here that would get through. I might ask um maybe I'll message
the potentially criminal and just see what he's thinking on this.
See if he gets a chance to look at this. Or maybe I'll just check
his stream at some point here. Uh, today or tomorrow. Hold on.
Potentially criminal.
I've got him on Discord now, so I could always just ask him.
What would he do tonight? He did not do He did not do this tonight.
I get the feeling that um I get the feeling that Pisco would
hate potentially criminal. I think Potentially Criminal is like
quite libertarian Republican leaning.
I think I saw in Pisco's VOD from today, I think he was watching
something with good logic and potentially criminal on it. Hold
on. There's some stuff there. I don't know. Should we read the
whole like destiny declaration? The whole
like there's a what? There's a Destiny declaration. There's a
Breler declaration. I think I've got most of the stuff together.
If anybody knows of like one of the exhibits that we should check
out, maybe we do that. Hold on. Let me see here. I I was kind
of curious what he's checking out earlier today. >> Doing
is building sympathy for someone else. So, what I routinely >> Oh,
some of the Charlie Kirk stuff. So, I saw potentially criminal.
I saw Good Logic and then Pisco's watching it. Pisco is like
a total outsider in that community, right? Like literally literally
every single one of the people in that community are like libertarian
right-leaning
people. And then there's like Pisco is the one like Law Tube
adjacent person I've seen who's like super progressive. It's
pretty funny.
Good logic is way more annoying. Um I think they're like they're
just like they're libertarians. I don't know how else to say
it other than um like they're not even libertarian. Sure. like
they they don't hate Trump. They're like boomers. I don't think
they're like horrible people. Like I think I'm I'm guessing both
Sean and um Good Logic would be like cool people to sit down
and have a beer with. They'd be like funny. They'd be they seem
like amiable people and then they get into like arguments about
this stuff and they're just like I guess Legal Eagle's probably
centered. I don't think Legal Eagle is really law tube though
as much as he's a lawyer. What else we got here? Got 15 minutes
left. I probably for these last 15 minutes unless there's something
else good in here. I think I've read through all the stuff I
super care about. We could look through some of these Steven
Benell declaration exhibits. Then real quick, let's just see
if we got this. Is Destiny posting his logs with Rose from his
side, right? To show So this is his thing that he created to
shows like logs with Rose.
Show the dates. And then the third one will be what? To show
comparisons. I do find it funny that like Oh, I also think um
Oh, I just figured out how Pixie does this, right? Pixie's team.
Okay, write this down. Write this down. Somebody write this down.
All right. Make sure it gets put on um make sure this this gets
sent to Pixie's team. Okay. Show the the clip, the time stamp
of Destiny saying how he edited this together himself, right,
for his view here. And then say, "We need a legal expert to come
in and check this out. We'll have to do it at trial."
Done. Right. Totally done.
Like this is a composite view that he made himself. We don't
know that he didn't [__] it up. We don't know that
he didn't screw something up. Yeah, sure. Sure. Yeah, I don't
think I don't know if he's trying to misremember, but he's kind
of So, listen. He confessed to sending child to a random YouTuber
who made a video on him and called the cops. Okay, he's
or sorry, retaining child. So, listen. He's not a smart guy.
He probably couldn't have done this without [__]
it up. Maybe he screwed something up. We We're going to have
to take another look. All right, we're just going to have to
take another look. He did this himself. It wasn't some expert
who did it. Anyway,
yeah, there you go. This is what the video name, the URL name
with Pixie video. This is all files sent to supposedly all files
sent to Abby, right? Okay.
F some Jesus Christ. Oh boy. So these are the logs we saw from
before. Major leaks probably. Uh my dark readers with it though.
Hold on.
Major leaks prob.
We don't get anything new here. So there's nothing that does
get leaked here. Kind of weird. kind of weird like the whole
time
peach sighting. Yeah, peach was referenced in these documents.
There's nothing there's nothing that we didn't already see when
we read the original document. I don't think there's anything
that we didn't already see. So, nothing really new here. See
you later, Kyoko. See you later.
>> Okay, we got 11 minutes left. I was just going to watch
some quick Pisco Autism.
It's like I'm dreaming.